you know it has to be blamed on white
supremacy because everything is blamed
on white supremacy these days
uh the the that horrible shooting in
atlanta the massage parlor
uh that was blamed on white supremacy
the anti-asian attacks more broadly
being blamed on white supremacy
there was some hit piece about me
there's always some hit piece about me
but from one of the media matters or one
of one of the leftist
attack groups saying that if you ever
make a joke
any kind of joke about the wuflu you
know you call it kung fluid or lung pow
sicken or
or any of those sorts of chop fluid was
the one or uh you know
any of the other i'm sorry that many of
the very funny terms are escaping my
my memory right now but that that is
perpetuating anti-white or anti-asian
bigotry
and white supremacy and the thing is the
numbers just
just don't show that uh ryan jardusky
has a great great piece on this in the
washington examiner according to the
justice department
uh 27.5 of all violent crimes against
asian americans in 2018
were committed not by white people they
were committed by black people
over 50 000 incidents in a single year
and a disproportionate to the percentage
of uh
black people in the country white
criminals and asian criminals each
accounted for
24.1 percent of all attacks on asians
that year
and so therefore asian attackers and
white attackers are
under represented in violent crime
uh relative to the their proportion of
the population
in 2019 asians made up 6.2 percent of
the population but commit
uh committed just one percent of the
violent crime and
white people 62 percent of the
population but commit 50
of violent crime so it's not to say that
there's any any one group is committing
all the violent crime against asians
but when you're talking specifically
about this issue of anti-asian crime
it is very clear the issue ain't white
supremacy
and and the the idea of white supremacy
is being pushed
uh simply to have a uh scapegoat
simply to have an explanation that would
jive with political correctness
even though it has nothing to do with it
there was a gal who took to tick-tock
as all of our brilliant philosophers do
these days and
she she made this point that i'm i am
sure is being taught
in corporate america in the schools
which is that
even non-white people when they commit
crimes can be doing so because of
whiteness just a reminder that whiteness
can still be the culprit
even if a hate crime is committed by
another minority
white supremacy has many mouthpieces
don't underestimate that
white supremacy has many mouthpieces
including all the racial minorities
attacking other racial minorities
because they don't realize that deep
secretly their motivation is their how
white they
are underneath their actual race and
motivations or something like that
uh doesn't make a whole lot of sense but
it's just the end of argument right
there
that gal is not making an argument i
don't blame her i'm sure she was
indoctrinated into this
uh through much of our culture this idea
that no matter
what the facts are you have to blame
whiteness or the patriarchy and it's
unfalsifiable and there is no debate
because there is no
there is not one piece of evidence that
you could ever present
to someone espousing that argument that
would change
their mind about it the argument that
whiteness and patriarchy or whatever the
cause of all the problems
that is not the conclusion of people who
have been thinking about this issue
that's the premise that's that's the
hammer
and therefore every other problem in
society
looks a whole lot like a nail if you
enjoyed that video be sure to hit the
subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content out there
you